rise and shine it's espresso time hey
it's evan carmichael and i am not a
morning person but when you start your
day with a powerful routine that
inspires you like watching one of these
videos it can change your life so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee know that i believe in you
and get ready for a shot of espresso
from brendan burchard
i wake up every morning
i get up in the morning i drink 20
ounces of water
i do 20 minutes of mobility movement and
stretching every morning
then i read for 20 minutes something
positive for me it's almost always a
self-help book or a leadership book
almost always sometimes a business book
almost always self-help and leadership
read that book then
i
go and i sit down
with my high performance planner
my green tea i fill out the day
right i look at the blocks of time that
are already scheduled
and then what i use is my second
visualization which is i look at the
major blocks of time that have been
scheduled just like this this morning
and i close my eyes
and i think
how do i do that thing with excellence
what would make that thing
special
so this morning before i got here when i
thought about this because there's my
high performance planner impact theory
tom bill you oh yes three exclamation
points literally so i looked at the
schedule it closed my eyes and i thought
okay
what do i want to communicate on tom's
show how do i want that to feel
what do i want to communicate so i
literally close my eyes and i visualize
those blocks of time
and how would i do them well
that's a superpower most people write
their day out and they just go about the
day and then they sometimes they come
back to the plan and they go oh my god i
didn't even do it
because i sit there and i think about
how do i do that well
that's the game changer there are three
words that are written on my phone
three words that every time i open my
phone i unlock it i see those words on
my background no matter what screen i go
to on my phone there's still those three
words
remember
your
intention
remember your intention remember your
intention i think one of the biggest
problems people have not just
entrepreneurs and people is
we don't set an intention we don't have
an intention we don't know what our
intention is
and then for those of us who do we just
don't remember them we're not consistent
in remembering what what we're doing and
why we're doing it like how many times
have you gotten to the end of a day or
another week and felt like you did so
much but
it didn't what nothing seemed to move
you ever you forgot there you got the
end of the week like it's friday
it's been a really busy week but when i
actually get accomplished and it turns
out not a heck of a lot
because it wasn't a lot of intention
i remember meeting um tom and brendan
at an event in puerto rico at brendan's
home
and
we're actually going to all connect
again in napa coming up soon
and brendan challenged me
on the first day to say hey
remember why you're here and you have to
ask a question
he says your problem is you're you're
always giving too much i mean it's
giving it's great it's not too much but
you're always giving you're always in
giving mode you're always sharing with
people how they can grow their channels
and have more you're always sharing
you need to ask i need you to ask you
have to make sure that you sit here and
you ask so when we do a round table and
i was really insecure so many big names
um at that meeting that first one was
tom and and lewis howes and jay shetty
and russell brunson and dean graziosi
and brendan burchard and jamie curran
lima who just sold their business for
1.3 billion dollars and all of these
highly successful entrepreneurs i'm sure
i'm missing a whole bunch of names
uh
and i felt like what am i going to bring
to the table i mean i'm
i'm going to teach
brandon bashar how to believe in himself
more right i mean it didn't it didn't
feel like i deserved to be there and so
i was really insecure about it and
brendan i got there earlier was the
first one there on the first day and
brendan found me and said hey
just make sure your intention today is
you you have to you're going to give by
default so that's fine but you need to
ask for something that
helped a lot that shifted my intention
away from just being insecure but how to
how to bring value and also ask hey what
do i need what do i actually need out of
this if i had one question that i could
ask all these successful entrepreneurs
what would it be
and that allowed me to ask a better
question because i showed up with more
intention
and so i want to give you the tools in
this video to live a more intentional
life and just try to nobody's going to
be 100 consistent so how can you stay as
consistent as possible so we're going to
look at three different phases
there's three different versions of it
okay step number one is is intentional
life so we're looking macro now what
does an intentional life look like for
you what does that mean when i say
intentional life what does that mean
what what kind of life do you want to
live what are your ambitions what are
your aspirations what are your desires
what are your dreams what are your goals
what was it intentional life like if you
could actually plan your life where do
you want to be spending your time you
don't want to be on a beach all day long
you don't nobody does you want to feel
like you're doing meaningful work so
what does that look like
what what do you look like as a human as
a as a father or as a mother as a
husband as a wife as a son or a daughter
as an entrepreneur like all the hats
that you wear
what does an intentional life look like
for you in terms of the in terms of the
habits that you're doing right
what does intentionality look like for
you what does success look like for you
and getting clear on that because when
you have a map it's a lot easier to then
start to live it when you don't know
where you're going you're wandering all
over the place so what is an intent when
i say that what does an intentional life
look like to you
what
comes to mind for all the different hats
that you wear and the three easiest
buckets are the relationship the career
finance um and then your your health
those are usually the three buckets that
things fall into so what does an
intentional life look like for you
step number two is what does an
intentional calendar look like for you
so now that we have our life
ideas in mind what does that translate
to on a daily basis
so for example in my life monday is my
mentoring day i meant to the people that
are on my team and that i've invested
into their businesses tuesday is my
youtube day today's a tuesday i'm
filming tuesday i'm i'm doing all my
youtube stuff i film videos i look at my
strategy
look at all my content all the
experiments and thumbnails and tests
that we're doing new ideas that's
tuesday wednesday's project day and i
get to pick a project that i want to
work on it might be my book it might be
movement makers might be brand lytics
might be whatever project i could just
be creative and spend the day working on
that project i think having
forced creativity in in little chunks is
hard i think to be creative and to make
something special you need you need
blocks of time
so that's wednesday thursday is my
public face today that's when i do
interviews and podcasts and skype calls
and whatever to help promote the
business people want me on their shows
and so that's all packed on a thursday i
do my movement makers on a thursday do
my brand linux on a thursday i need to
show up for the public
so it's extrovert hat on and let's go
let's go beat the drum of believe
friday is my ceo day and that's where i
work on the big projects to grow my
business there's nothing scheduled on a
friday uh it's basically big big like
wednesday with the tragic day but more
like hey how do i where am i trying to
go what do i want to accomplish what's
missing in my business in my life and
just giving me again even more
freedom instead of structure to think
about where i want to go
saturday is fun day and saturday is the
day that i spend with nina my family
and
whatever we want to do know what no
chores no admin it might be hiking that
might be a new restaurant might be some
festival
just obviously planned an entire
saturday full of fun for us to do and
then sunday's family admin day costco
grocery shopping cleaning the condo
laundry like all the stuff you have to
do
as a human
but it's not on saturday right we're not
going grocery shopping saturday is fun
day and then it all repeats and goes
back to the same schedule on monday
that's an intentional calendar for me so
it's an intentional life of how i want
to live and then the calendar is set up
so that if i did these things will i get
closer to achieving the life that i want
success is the habits you can have goals
great but where is your where in your
calendar actually going to focus on
achieving your goals
so
when you set up your intentional life
great now let's create a calendar so
that those things are there if you want
if you have you know health goals
well where are you going to be
exercising and working out where are you
going to be
spending time to go buy the healthy food
and to cook the healthy food that you
want to be eating instead of not
exercising eating mcdonald's every night
right because if it's not in your
calendar you're not going to do it you
can have the best intentions but if it's
not in your calendar you're not going to
do it so you have to put it in your
calendar in a realistic way that you can
stick to
and it's possible
we're just not doing it
and so it remains as some goal
i want to make content i want to make a
youtube channel great where in your
calendar are you spending making youtube
videos and until it's in your calendar
it's not going to happen consistently
it's going to be too much
off the whim of oh i just feel like
doing it today so i'm going gonna do it
if you wait till you have time to do
something you're never gonna do it
so you have to schedule it in
intentionally
so level one of intention is intentional
life level two of intention is an
intentional calendar and then level
three of intention is an intentional day
and even moment by moment in the day
so
before i make videos today i'll ask
myself what what's my intention for this
activity why is remember your intention
on my cell phone because i want to start
the day looking at my calendar and
saying how do i want to show up and when
i look at each individual task i ask
myself how do i want to show up how do i
want to show up for this video i want to
show up
inspired
i want to help people believe in
themselves more i want to create one of
the best videos i've ever made i want to
have energy
i want to i want to pour light into
people
so that's the intention if you if you
even just talk out the intention
before you do the thing
you'll show up better you show up
different you show up
with that energy that you wanted
especially when you have to switch to
something else at 2 30 i'm going to
spend time with my wife and we're going
to go for a walk take the dogs now it's
you know nice sunny day here and in
toronto we're going to go for a walk and
that requires me to switch intention
then i'm going to switch back to making
more videos then i'm going to spend more
time with nina over dinner then i'm
going to spend time with my son we're
going to do some minecraft uh it
requires if i'm if i'm thinking about
youtube videos while i'm having dinner
with nina or playing minecraft and
hanging out with my son
i'm not present for them
i might be there spending time but i'm
not really there
you can spend hours with somebody
watching a movie or lounging watching
netflix but never actually connect with
them versus a 25-minute walk together
could be much more connection than most
people have in a week
so in order to do that it's you have to
switch the gears and just remind
yourself what's my intention for this
and that could take 10 seconds it
doesn't have to be this 30 minute
activity every time you switch tasks
just how do i want to show up for this
when i have dinner with nina tonight how
do i want to show up
i'm now making youtube videos i'm
showing up as entrepreneur evan changing
lives spreading belief spreading hope
inspiration positivity let's go
when i show up for five o'clock dinner
with my wife what how do i want to show
up i want to show up as a caring husband
i want to be supportive
and just asking
myself that question forces me to be a
better husband when i show up for dinner
as opposed to still being in youtube
mode
right see the difference
and so
it's an intentional life
then it's an intentional calendar
and it's an intentional day and even
intentional moments inside the day so
you can look back and say i did five
different things today and i showed up
for all five of those as i wanted to
show up and nobody gets it perfect i
still don't get it perfect
but even just the reminder and the aim
to get better
leads you to have a much more
intentional life
successful life and most importantly
happy life
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the sign says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action
of when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else that jumps to 95 percent chance
from 30 something percent to 95 chance
of you following through believe nation
we need to make this happen so question
of the day your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
listen humans are built to serve some
people are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them but in either case
humans are built to serve so if you're
not happy right now it's because you're
not serving enough you got to pick up
this book because it's so inspiring to
remind you that we're all here to
contribute to make a difference to make
an impact and this is your field guide
for that you don't have and have not
developed friendships
with other people who you talk to enough
who are doing the activities of the
dream
and trust me i know that like as a
writer i mean you guys see me on youtube
and instagram and like doing videos all
the time with our challenges and our
courses and our podcast oh my god
but
i'm more introverted than you think i
would be
like i can go out and just crush it to
an arena of 30 000 people all day long
no problem but then i need to go back
and just like not talk to a human for a
while i have a big introverted like part
of my life and as a writer
i would write by myself all the time
and i wouldn't collaborate with anyone i
didn't have any friends who were writers
and so i was always impatient i'm like
is this book ever going to happen
am i ever going to get published am i
ever gonna have a best seller and i was
losing patience
because i didn't have community
when you have community like literally
friends who you can call and go you know
what today sucked i didn't get anything
done i didn't create or hey you know
what
i'm just not feeling anymore i wonder if
i should quit
but they're on the path with you they're
like hey no
don't quit hey listen to that dream that
was sewn in your heart follow that work
for that earn that like having positive
friends
who are on the same journey
is one of the most critical things that
people
fail to set up
because what people running people say
well brendan uh but i just don't have
any friends so i guess i'm gonna fail
like then go make friends leave your
house people like but i don't know
anyone doing this i'm like go volunteer
for an organization that's doing
something related to your dream oh i
don't i don't know anybody in my local
community who's not a jerk i'm like go
volunteer because guess who volunteers
good people giving people people who
want to make a difference people willing
to give their time money effort towards
good causes get around them and as
you're around them start asking do you
know anyone who does
this thing
i just started getting around everybody
in volunteer organizations when i was
coming up in my 20s and i would say hey
do you know anyone who's like a writer
who like you know writes articles or
blogs or books and they're like good at
it
and these people i was volunteering with
like oh yeah i know this person go talk
to this person i'd get an introduction
i'd ask them go out to lunch and i'm
like and i would just ask them questions
and then we became friends the next
thing i know we're going to lunches
we're going to the bar we're hanging out
and now i'm in that world when you are
in the world of your dream
it's here
you're touching it daily because of your
social relationships so make sure you
develop friends who are doing what you
want to do it will carry you through
those dark days when otherwise you'd
strive by yourself the first thing you
have to do in order to improve your mind
is take total control of your attention
and notice where are your thoughts right
now
at a very continual basis you have to
think where are my thoughts right now
are they supporting me or are they
automatically coming up negative and
self-protective in ways that are not
advancing my life
just to be aware to be conscious of
what's going on in your body in your
sense of feeling and emotion and the
sense of the thoughts you're actually
having just start paying attention you
know for a lot of people because they've
never done this before and it's hard to
remind them to do it it's like simple
here's what i want you to do just start
paying attention to your thoughts
anytime you're in line
any time you're in line from now on if
you're in line at starbucks just say i'm
in line at starbucks brennan said think
about my thoughts what are my thoughts
saying right now just checking in you're
in line in traffic waiting for the next
car to sit and think what are my
thoughts right now and just notice what
you've been thinking about the more we
notice what we've been thinking about
the more we can interrupt
what we've been thinking about see if we
just allow that feeling to keep coming
up and you don't pay attention to it our
life can be very frazzled and very
highly anxious but once we say what's my
mind on right now and we redirect it
that is where personal power comes from
first awareness
right and understanding and the
consciousness of what's going on but
then the ability now to be self-directed
to choose what we want to focus on so
first we're attentive to it and then
redirect it if it's negative it's not
supporting you redirect it how do you
redirect it first and foremost you just
say what would be the opposite of this
negative thing then you think about the
positive thing and you focus on that and
you repeat it to yourself for many
people that might include closing their
eyes just visualizing a more positive
outcome
thinking about the more positive outcome
thinking about the more positive outcome
thinking about the more positive
outcomes focusing on with their eyes
closed and that visualization of a more
positive outcome of how things could
turn out well or how good the situation
could be better or even just what are
the next steps i should take
visualizing that and assigning a high
amount of importance and duration to it
meaning making that thing important to
us by making it how do you make
something important you give it a
sensation
you feel that thing you sense it you
sense what your next step would be you
sense how and feel if the outcome would
be better how would it feel emotionally
psychologically spiritually for that
thing to allow it to have a lot of
emotion to it pay attention to your eyes
close you see that thing you feel it you
sense a different step you know what
you're going to do you pay attention to
it and you keep focusing on that just
over a period of minutes keep focusing
and keep focusing focusing when your
mind automatically wants to go back to
the easy which might be negative
you go no no i don't want to i don't i'm
not into easy right now i'm into
conditioning my mind
focus focus focus focus give attention
duration and sensation to it attention
duration sensation attention duration
sensation visualization visualization
it's repetition of that positive
alternative to a negative impulse that
comes up that gives us personal power
let me say it again it's that attention
to that positive alternative
over attention to repeating that
negative impulse or thought that gives
us personal power you know so many
people say to me well brendan i'm wiped
out i'm tired i i wish i had your energy
or whatever i know a lot of people don't
want to have my energy it's too annoying
i get it
but what if we had you tap back into
your aliveness again you know what if
you just chose not for any reason not
for what emotions come up in your human
body because emotions just come up right
your nervous system sometimes you don't
even know why you feel what you feel
like something can be trigger you a
sound a movement something someone says
or just your physical body of what you
ate a couple hours ago or how much you
slept three days ago can catch up to you
and your body and your emotions can kind
of go
but we have the saying the power plant
doesn't have energy
it generates energy
what if your dominant frame
said you know i'm going to focus on my
aliveness and you started cultivating an
aliveness in your body and in your mind
for no other reason than i said so no
other reason that you decided to you
said you know what today i'm going to
focus on what's great about me but i'm
also going to focus on being fully alive
and engaged and present how do you do
that just what if you just felt more
grateful for the life that you had
you know look you're breathing you're
you're you're alive you we we have this
incredible gift that we're all here
right now you know it's like i'm here
you're here what if we took that
seriously and we started realizing what
a gift it is to be alive and we allowed
ourselves to feel alive not for any
reason no one made us happy no one did
anything for us we just felt alive again
and we started asking ourselves on a
daily basis what level of aliveness do i
feel in my body right now do i feel at a
level zero like dead
or do i feel like a level 10 i'm fully
alive fully engaged fully present and we
willed ourself into feeling more alive
every day it's the number one question i
get from all of my work is like wow you
have a lot of energy on what you do how
do you get it i don't get it i don't
find it i generate it the power plant
doesn't have energy it generates it if
you want to feel better about your life
generate more aliveness for no other
reason than you choose to life should be
incredibly
valuable to you if you really value your
days like that day becomes valuable so
because your day is valuable you get
stuff done you know why a lot of people
end up feeling really broke is because
they're not valuing their day they're
broke because they added no value to
their day they were reading celebrity
gossip magazines they were screwing
around online they were doing nothing
that actually moved the needle in terms
of their personal progress and their
professional progress so value this day
you want to make more money get serious
about tomorrow value that day ask how
you can add more value into the day
really work the day and as you do that
over and over and over again you ask how
can i serve how can i contribute how can
i take it to the next level you do that
long enough
the breakthrough happens the magic
happens and the money
takes care of itself most people don't
have a calendar
so that's problem number one
they're not strategically blocking time
moving towards
the major things they want in their life
they won't say they're going through the
motions but the calendar reveals it like
if i parachute in their life and i open
up their calendar and there's nothing
there they can't possibly say they're
living with purpose or intention and
that sounds so flippant to say but i
can't believe how many people
they're not planning their skill set
development they're not planning
specific goal attainment on certain
dates so just like their calendar is
completely empty and they're hoping it's
going to happen and it's like you look
at mine it's like it's like
military-esque like planning big biases
i had
that were wrong
and you're not gonna like this one and
no one's going to like it but creativity
is not strongly correlated with high
performance
i would have three years ago i would
argue i mean i would have been i would
have been passionately argued against
because i'm a creative yeah this is my
life i write i train i speak that's what
i i would have argued forever i've
designed all the covers of my books yeah
i mean i dork out about design i design
all my web pages i'm i believe that
creativity must give the edge and it
does give an edge in some
certain circumstances for sure
but uh i interviewed a fortune 50 cto
chief technology officer
unbelievably high performing people
their stocks off the roof and but what
he said we go is brendan i'm not a
creative person my team isn't
particularly creative but long-term
success matters just as much about
execution and consistency and showing up
as the creative edge the creative edge
might get you in the game because
remember high performance is long-term
success we're not studying initial
success it's very initial success you
know grit creativity originality all
these things very important the spark
the get you in the game for sure but
even jim rohn said you know motivation
gets you in the game habits keep you
there and creativity uh as a habit that
the spark that might be called
original creativity it might only happen
for us every two to three years so
that's not sufficient we got to show up
on monday and tuesday and wednesday
execution is more important as an
example so we talk about the kinds of
creativity that actually matter
but it's not strongly correlated almost
across all industries and i would have
completely argued with that last night
i'm going on the stage right if i if my
identity says i am a public speaker
and it is important for me to be
excellent at this
and then i go on stage and i bomb
what does that say about me as a person
so we've got about 50 years of work in
psychology in the field of psychology
saying do not tie your efforts to your
identity because
that risk of disappointment or rejection
you know if the task fails
you shouldn't take that as as a defining
moment in which you say i am a failure
right so that's the risk and that's what
you know psychologists tell us to be
wary of except it turns out that high
performers flipped on its face and go
well actually um
no i do get bothered
if it fails i really get upset about it
i am attached to the process here i i do
care if it turns out well i mean that's
why they obsess about the details that's
why they care about excellence is like
no one obsessed about the details or
cares about excellence unless it means
something to them
and there is a risk the risk is
you over attach
to the process of the outcome
with your identity so that if the
process or outcome goes bad now you feel
bad about yourself as a human
and now you stop your progress
but i also tell people
there's a balance there i actually wish
more people would attach some identity
to what they're doing they wouldn't go
through the motions as much i mean
i think what the world needs
less of is half interested parents who
don't have an identity that says you
know what
i'm going to be an excellent parent
i think we have a lot of ceos or
business people or entrepreneurs who
they've never stepped in and said you
know what
i'm a ceo
i own this business i am responsible for
paying the bills i am responsible for
making the money i'm responsible for all
these people's mortgages who work for me
like they i want them to own the
identity of a ceo because most of them
if you ask them about their identity and
their business they're kind of like you
come to find
they're kind of approaching it like
not even hobbyists
it's like if you want to win
your identity has to be tied into that
thing in which you are trying to succeed
at and give to and that takes a lot of
guts to put yourself all in for
something but who's ever contributed
something with tremendous impact without
being all into it i've never seen it so
i think the message of the book you're
right i'll get some flack of
a lot of psychologists say don't don't
tell people to tie more of their
identity or my friends who are buddhists
will say but attachment is the form of
all suffering brennan have you not read
your spiritual texts i'm like look out
calm down i've hung out with the dalai
lama i'm totally cool
but what i'm trying to tell you is even
the dalai lama
has a connection with himself as a
spiritual leader his identity is still
there that people you know assume that
you know we have to release ourselves
from having any attachment to something
but i'm like i think
we all want to be present and engaged
fully
in the things that we are doing in our
lives
and that's going to require us to say
psychologically you know what i
i
am all in this the habit is generate
energy
okay not necessarily have energy create
energy create energy and what they do
the way we measure that was kind of
academic
mental energy which is tied to your
focus and your stamina and your ability
to manage complex tasks without too much
mental stress
number two is emotional energy
which is just the quality of positive
emotions
and number three is physical energy
high performers are 40
more likely to work out five times per
week
than
the rest of their peers so that means
the top 15
most high performing people in the world
tend to work out five days per week
and that workout could be defined as you
know 45 minute brisk walk or you know
hit intensity or whatever it is but
40 more likely that's a huge finding
and what we found is high performers
just have
better well-being
and happiness and physical conditioning
than everybody else
one stunning finding was uh
ceos
senior executives and business owners
they report expending as much energy
as athletes who are competitive now i
can imagine yeah yeah i kind of i was
surprised by that i would thought you
know athletes would be 10 more i mean
the emotional
the decision making the conversations
the big deals the stakeness
yeah it's a lot of energy it's a lot
that's why
i mean if you really want to achieve
your dreams you have to care for your
body yeah your mind it's why all these
things you know finally resonating in
the marketplace because the science of
meditation or taking a break
or you know uh
managing your own energy sleep is
everything yeah um and i think all of
that is really important and we say
generate energy because there's this
myth that
you know some people have happiness or
they have it's like
no you generate you don't have happiness
you generally create it yeah you create
it and so
the quality of your energy you have to
create like you and i both i mean if
most of our audience knew
our schedules your schedule the last
five days is like how is lewis even able
to focus right now and how are you able
to get here and do this as well yeah but
it's because we say well this is our
mission
show up man yeah you know there's plenty
of times i gotta imagine you walked on
the field and you were like
i'm spam exhausted you know i remember
when you like flew down to compete and
yeah i still play with the usa team
handball yeah team and a year ago i flew
down to
i remember i did an interview in miami
and then flew out from miami and then
went and just went right into training
camp and then played against brazil
which is like you know olympic
olympic qualifiers and yeah got our
assets booked but it was fun you know
but i had to have clarity yeah show up
even when i was like oh we're going to
lose yeah like there's deer a chance
yeah it was like the worst team in the
nba playing like the warriors and we
were just like we had no chance yeah but
i had to show up and give my best and
you have to set all these routine i mean
you know the amount of routines tom
brady has in his life so that he can
generate energy it's unbelievable stuns
most people it's unbelievable and that's
just that's that's what it takes if you
want to get that level if you don't want
to be at that level you don't have to do
it yeah you don't have to do it i mean
everybody can just like well i'm going
to go you know hit the cinnabon but it's
like
it's pretty good how do you want to feel
at three o'clock if you want to feel
amazing at three o'clock don't end lunch
with a cinnabon you know you wrote that
achievement is not the problem alignment
is
can we talk about that a little bit yeah
uh i wish it was my line it was uh one
of my clients she's uh
i mean she manages over ten thousand
people like she has ten thousand direct
reports she's she's just an unbelievable
achiever and when i started working with
her
i mean
just like a lot of people their
struggles aren't
can i make a goal list and a checklist
and you know can i get things done
because people get stuff done all the
time but our busy work isn't always our
life's work and so you have to learn
that
we have to find that
thing
that we can align to
and a lot of people they're achieving
themselves into the wrong thing they put
the ladder against the wrong building
they
just haven't really figured out what's
important to them and most importantly
alignment also includes harmony in your
life because a lot of people achieve
achieving their career and then they're
divorced achieve achieve and achieve and
they're fat and they didn't take care of
themselves and and they know it and it
sounds horrible to say it but they know
it and so you have to figure out like
okay how can we
align ourselves something that we really
care about and not align like sometimes
on a monday or tuesday or not just in
our career but really get our
relationships our health our career all
in alignment to help us become a high
performing because high performing isn't
just achievement for achievement's sake
i also every morning
lay in bed and
i visualize what i want
and i see it like when first time i wake
up i literally just lay there for an
extra two three four minutes and i just
kind of visualize and i'm thinking about
the things that i want so that happens
every morning
are you willing to share an example
actual example so from age of 20
to 26
uh probably 90 of the time
i would lay there and i would see myself
on stages big stages
and i would sit there and as soon as
that image came up i'd
freak out
like i'd imagine myself walking on a
stage
with an arena and i would literally just
start sweating in bed i'd lay there in
bed terrified like just awfully
uncomfortable because
that wasn't me
but i was like
everyone was saying your car accident
story brennan really
made a difference in my life
uh this whole idea of having reverence
for life and having you know the
intention of who you want to be all
these simple things that we talk about
personal development but i'd share my
story of people and think oh my gosh you
need to teach that and i was like oh i
started hearing that i said maybe i'll
learn to teach i learned to talk only be
more expressive because where i'm from i
grew up in an irish mining town
that had been economically depressed for
a century
like men didn't communicate
there was no emotional expression if
their hands came above their waist they
were punching you in the face you know i
mean it was a very physical and very
violent place i grew up in but there
wasn't
emotional expression so i laid there and
i'd see myself like talking and moving
on stage if you visualize yourself on
stage
people are watching now or listening now
if you close your eyes and you see
yourself on stage public speaking with
no podium no notes to
10 000 people in arena
most people will get clammy hands and
start sweating if you really see it and
think about it and feel it and put
yourself there for two to three minutes
i did that for six years for three to
five minutes every morning
i'd hear myself saying something i'd see
myself moving i'd see the audience
clapping or jumping up at the end i'd
see myself moving across the stage in
ways i never moved
and that visualization
created that skill set
because then i'd go and i'd sometimes
i'd wake up and
i was like oh i was good i try it out
on the carpet you know i'd get up like
oh i like that i try it out and i try it
out just in my little dorm room
then my little apartment
and i was always trying things out and i
always wanted to get better at it and
always want to get better at it so it
just depends sometimes as a specific
goal like right now i'm also work on
some you know major media goals you have
to be all in and it's the hardest thing
to do because if it fails then you can
feel like a failure um you know
i think of this idea of performance
necessity
two stories kind of come to mind one is
i was working with an olympic gold
medalist sprinter and we're in the
tunnel and we're going out and he's
talking about the competition and we get
out to the blocks and i said uh he was
really worried about the competition i
said well how do you engage like who who
who's going to win
you know in in his particular race
people are winning but by you know 1
100th of a second tenths of a seconds i
mean these are really close sprints and
i said well how how do you know i said
who would you even bet on
and he says
you know i would
bet on the guy
who gets down at the blocks
gets himself settled looks at the finish
line and says
i got to do this
for my mom
and i was like ooh
that's good his performance necessity in
that is
it's necessary for him to win that race
for his mom
um i think of
you know when i started
my career and i really decided to go all
in
with writing and online training um this
is like 2000 probably six
uh i'd gone broke completely bankrupt
and failed i left my corporate job i had
this cushy kind of corporate job as a
consultant good job um left it to write
and i didn't know how to make it as a
writer i want to do seminars workshops
didn't know how to do that so i was
pretty much a hot mess ran out of money
um i got nothing to my name
nothing kind of no positive prospects no
one's calling me except the guys who
want the money
and um
one night i'm riding and the apartment
was so small on the bed i had uh
all you know what my bills my vision
boards all my research
all my journals like the bed was
basically the desk the extended desk and
my lady comes in denise and
she
walks past me but she sees i'm like
trying to write so it doesn't want to
disturb me she goes she crawls under
the covers of the bed
and i'm just typing kind of casually
typing away
and i look over
[Music]
and
i see my woman
sleeping under my bills
and it was just like
you know
because none of us want to see our you
know
our family suffer because we are
not performing sure
and um
i was just like
i gotta figure this out
and i'm telling you i wrote more that
night than any night in my entire life
next day i wrote more than ever that
burst life scold and ticket became a
bestseller and in you know 18 months
later because i was like i'm going to
figure out this online thing i mean
throughout marketing i'm going to figure
out how to teach i'm going to how to
train and get paid for it because i've
never really been paid for those things
i said i'm going to figure out this
industry and i'm going to make it 18
months later after her
crawling under the bills i made 4.6
million dollars jesus online
total transformation people like how did
you do it i'm like she gave me she was
my necessity i was not going to let my
woman
be in that situation
um and she believed in me she supported
me she she married me
and uh you know but that was she was my
drive
and the second part was i went all in
with my identity i said i am going to be
a great writer
and i am going to be one of the greatest
online trainers there ever was
you know as you said in the intro now
we've graduated over two million people
have taken our online courses video
series now
i don't think it would have happened if
i hadn't had the guts and maybe
the no other choice
to say this is who i'm going to be
and i'm going to build into that
and it's necessary for me to become that
person
so let's go one of the major major keys
we found the first high-performing habit
is seek clarity
and what we found is
one of the practices that high
performers do
is they define the feeling they're after
and so when we had to explain that and
later talk about it in the energy
chapter we had to differentiate between
feelings and emotions and they are
different emotions tend to be they're
the same like we have they're physical
they're almost always automatic even
though in the brain is creating
associations there's also happen for us
they just kind of emotion comes up yeah
you're watching a movie and you're just
sad and you're like oh my gosh you know
i'm crying you didn't even have the
tissues right you're just like
you know uh but the feelings are usually
interpretations that we make of what
that emotion was and how it sticks and
the meaning we give it to it yeah and
the example i used you know i like to
give and i don't remember if it's in the
book or not honestly because here's
what's happened this book is 400 pages
it was
hundred and eighty one when i finished
baby you edited
it was 1481 good complete like it was
like awesome yes but i was like that's
gonna freak people out so we're
publishing a bunch in academic journals
later and then stripped it down to 400
pages so it's more readable and fun and
orientable so i can't remember if this
one actually made it in there but um the
example i like to give is if you and i
go to a
haunted house yeah which i love i love
them i love them and they scare me the
crap but if you and i walk around you
know you walk around on the walls in a
haunted house someone jumps out at you
yeah you and i are both going to jump
yes we are emotionally going to
experience fright
immediately it's going to be there right
but i might be freaked out for the next
five minutes
and you might be laughing
why it's the meaning and the feeling
that we've defined it as
that's fine for everybody here's the
issue that people have and you have to
be careful about when we start talking
about energy because emotional energy is
real yes and that is look if at six like
we we go to the haunted house at you
know 5 p.m in the afternoon
if at 9 00 pm now you're in your house
you're alone but you're completely safe
and you still feel
scared
that's not the haunted house's problem
that is the way that you are defining
and working through your own emotions
you had the emotion of terror and fear
and you're still
experiencing that feeling
that's a mental job
not an emotional job so your job is to
go wow
i'm at my house i've i've lived here for
10 years i've never been threatened this
house this is a safe place
i got to redefine the feeling i want to
experience and i work with one an
olympic sprinter gold medalist olympic
sprinter as a client and
this person's huge breakthrough
in getting better and going from
literally uh one olympics before not
meddling at all to now gold i said what
made like what was the thing yeah and
one of the things they said to me was i
learned to define the feeling
and i said what do you mean by that and
he basically said you know if if
if there's a bunch of us at the starting
box and we're all in perfect poise in
perfect condition the one to bet on is
the one that says this is the way i want
to feel in this race right now i know my
emotions are going crazy like my heart's
beating i can hear everybody i'm waiting
for that shot blast i can see my goal i
know how important this is and all these
um like their emotions are there yeah
but that person is defining the feeling
i'm going to feel centered now
i'm going to get myself in the zone now
even though the anxiety is the emotion
of anxiety is there for all olympic
level com competitors all of them but
they define that feat that emotion as a
feeling that helps give them a
performance edge
and i think that's important too you
know bruce springsteen says if he's ever
backstage and doesn't feel like
nerves he's going to hang it up yeah
but that's anxiety he's just defining it
differently so what's the first social
habit
uh increased productivity
it's kind of like no duh high performers
are productive dudes um but what
what the uniqueness is they've
they're not just pushing more paper or
checking more boxes because you know i
both know a lot of people who you know
their busy work isn't their life's work
so they don't feel fulfilled for their
productivity high performers are
fulfilled from what they're
accomplishing which is a big big big
measure
and here's what they did they identified
their primary field of interest
which is a big deal
then they identified what we call pqo
prolific quality output which is what's
the outputs that matter and get
recognized and rewarded the most
in this primary field of interest
and then they went all in at it
they became almost singular focuses like
you know when when jobs came back to
apple and got rid of all the product
lines that these are what we're doing
that was prolific quality output we're
gonna be prolific quality output on
these things not those
so it's important like for me
i thought for there was this period of
my life
where i thought my primary field of
interest was personal development
and that's what most the world knows me
for i i've never posted any marketing on
my facebook page in terms of like
marketing advice uh i teach that
that's way down in my funnel
my front my youtube my podcast
facebook are all just personal
development so i really identified with
that
and then i launched my first book life's
golden ticket which was my life's
message
and it kind of bombed
it hit best seller and then it died you
know bam wow yeah
and really bummed me out
and i realized why i said you know what
i've been thinking my primary field of
interest is
personal development
and so i folk i did all the book i read
all the books i went to all the seminars
i you know studied with the gurus i
became friends with you know wayne dyer
and tony robbins with the big names
that's what i thought it was
and then i had to make a shift and i
shift my primary field of interest
to
how to share a message
and it completely shift
when i started learning i was like you
know what my primary field of interest
needs to be is how to share a message
because i already got the message right
and i said well what's prolific in this
area what's prolific is is what's
recognized in this particular area right
at that time with this 2006-7
online video was just coming in i mean
youtube and facebook were young youtube
was like 2004 i think yeah 2005 or
something young
and
but what's mattering now is video and i
went all in
you know i've created 13 online courses
because in my primary field of interest
sharing that personal development
message was everything so i learned how
to share everything and i went from you
know kind of
a busted
uh
first book to an 18 months
4.6 million in revenue wow
because i learned how to sell and i
learned that sharing and selling a
message was just as important because if
you don't make the money you can't
sustain the message i had the message
but i wasn't making any money i was the
poor broke writer dude and i was like
so i shifted my primary field of
interest and i went i got to understand
marketing i got to understand business
and what's going to be prolific in those
in what i'm doing now
and that's creating products to sell
oh i got to create more products higher
quality products i showed you like my
brochures and yeah beautiful stuff just
like super branding you know all my
books uh you know i i created i did all
the covers of all my books and i
obsessed about i was like the look and
the feel and stuff i didn't care about
before
and
that changed everything so what i tell
people is if you want to increase don't
just get more stuff done get more of the
right stuff done
and really go in on it i mean super
obsessed about the quality
and really focus you know it's that old
saying the main thing
is keep
is to keep the main thing
the main thing exactly yeah oh you got
you very careful what your main thing is
the big huge finding that really
scratches the surface of a lot of like
cultural assumptions
especially in high performance is this
big cultural conversation we have about
strengths and you know find your
strengths follow your strengths the
strengths are everything and you know
take the strengths finder figure out
your top five strengths follow those
don't do anything else or you know at
least know what they are and really aim
your career to that or aim your behavior
towards that or you know use that as a
guide for recognizing pattern and by the
way i'm all for that that's all great
i'm that guy who says you know any
self-reflection you do i'm cheering you
on
like any assessment any tool that makes
you look at with inside i'm like all for
it it's just that
strengths
are not highly correlated with long-term
success right there's not a lot of data
and there is not a lot of research that
has shown it leads to long-term success
with the positive outcomes uh associated
with what we care about in psychology
which is we care about happiness we care
about health and we care about your
positive relationships
and this myth that oh just follow our
strengths to you know
to the promised land
is just not true when you actually talk
with high performers
because my favorite question then if it
was down this just go up to anyone who's
good and say were you always good at
that
and then be like
no they're like not at all
well did you always have an inclination
to do every element of do where you're
doing really well no like me
man i sucked on stage this year i've
talked to 60 000 people live this is
really important because
this idea that we're just our strengths
are going to give us everything it's
just it's just not true i sucked
speaking on stage
matter of fact i was terrified of it
terrified
but one reason i love your show
is because i had that intention of i
want to make an impact
and when someone actually asks
and and kind of owns that like when they
say do i want to make an impact and the
answer is yes and they own it
they realize they're going to have to
develop they can no longer leave their
growth to
meet you know to to to randomness
because if they do they'll always be
mediocre and they realize i got to
become something entirely above both of
those
that's what most people don't see
they're like
it's we made this binary
false conversation right it's a it's
it's not a true
sort of choice here it's a false
dichotomy we call it right it's not
strengths or weaknesses many of you if
you have a big dream a huge goal you got
to become something entirely above and
beyond any strengths you even know about
feel or own and go way beyond any
weaknesses you've ever even addressed or
even you know about because you're going
to discover so many new strengths and so
many new weaknesses on the path
that it's almost irrelevant what they
are now it's what's the goal and build
into that you know i didn't know how to
write
i get a lot of critics who are like
literary guys about my books because
every book is different right six books
all of them different
and the reason they all read differently
is i am challenging myself as a writer
to develop
to get better every book i write i'm
going to write this like nothing i've
ever written before
and i go to work at building a new skill
set to be able to write like manifesto
i researched for two and a half years
just how to write it wow not what to
write
how how do i get that pentameter how do
i what was the rhythm in which
revolutionist rhetoric
was spoken in or written in just to
understand that took me two and a half
years so i had no conceptual
understanding of it it wasn't a strength
i didn't even it wasn't it wasn't on my
radar make small changes and see
themselves making those changes
and then integrate that into their
identity integration if you heard me
talk about it it's a big topic in high
performance it's it's one reason
successful people often don't feel like
successful people or successful people
don't feel confident because they've
never integrated the wins
the w-i-n-s wins they've they've had a
lot of wins in their life but they never
stopped and said
wow
i really appreciate that i got a little
better today
i really appreciate that putting myself
out there i'm proud of myself for trying
here um you know what i am a little
stronger because i did that thing
to acknowledge that you've gained some
strength
is everything to confidence isn't it
write it down to acknowledge that you
gain some strength
look i if you had two kids and you
survived you've gained some strength
you get a little more confidence in life
i mean come on what else do you have to
be through if you've already made some
money in your business but it's always
more more and more and more and you
never stop to go
wow i really came from nothing i made
some money here
and you never integrated the win in your
identity your identity stays the same
level over here
even though you've actually accomplished
a lot over here
and i see that all the time it's why i
see people who are the same level of
confidence in their 20s and 30s and now
they're 50 and 60 leading other people
but they're completely racked with
insecurity every night they feel like
crap they don't know what they're doing
and i'm like oh my gosh you should have
so much more confidence you should feel
good about yourself integrate some of
these wins four day event
and it's just me i usually have one or
two big names come in but it's me 12
hours a day four days and i never sit
down high energy i never sit down on
stage
and super high energy i mean really
going for it not just the clapping and
the jumping but really just spending
heart you know how hard it is of course
and uh i had to about the same time when
i was 35 i had a
a famous strength and conditioning coach
backstage he works with me in usher and
and he uh he's like what do you eat back
here and you know another guy came in
and strapped the heart rate monitor
machine he goes
i'm equivalently burning
uh equally working out at the marathon
level
every day
for four days
they're like you're not e i was losing
on average 11 pounds in my 70 years
every man i do eight events a year so i
was losing 88 pounds a year
you know it was like it's horrible for
your health so i had to learn how to eat
i had to learn i do ice baths every
night at my events which smart no one
loves to do that
here's the thing i used to do it every
day in football like during the season
yeah and we it sucks for the first month
but then you start to love it yes yeah i
have to do it you know what i mean it's
like you just start to ah i feel so good
so it feels so good after stage you know
it's last 12 hours so those are
no one says i want a habit of taking an
ice bath at the end of the day
but if i want to be high performing on
stage
that's the choice yeah now obviously
people listening you know consult your
doctor of course yeah yeah yeah um
they don't do it for 10 minutes don't
stand for half an hour yeah right right
so but all those things you have to so
what are your habits for energy and the
funny thing is you sit down with high
performers they know him they can tell
you i do this this this this you're like
man you're on your game i need to do a
good job here and i'm motivated by that
not scared by that yeah it's a perfect
little connection there's a whole
chapter on in the book and what often
happens for people is that emotional
thing we're talking about earlier like
that olympian that olympian that emotion
of anxiety
is that's they're using that to raise
their necessity to do better they're
like i'm gonna use this feeling i have
and transform it to do better yes even
though everyone else would identify that
same emotions i'm scared they're gonna
say this feeling is gonna make me focus
this feeling that i wanna have right now
i'm gonna you know put my a game on yeah
and it's so cool because all the high
performers i interviewed over 300
literally verified high performers we
use objective measures whether they're
highest performing in their company or
whether they fill out the high
performance uh indicator and we have
this assessment now that can basically
show these you're probably a high
performer if you score in these areas
and these six different habits and
interviewed over 300 of them and every
one of them at some point in the
interview and these are structured
academic interviews so they're way less
fun than this
and so i'm sorry for everyone who i
interviewed but boy uh it's just
different and and what i found out was
every one of them talked about that at
some point
taking
what they were experiencing and
transforming it into something that gave
them performance edge whether it's a an
artist readying themselves to touch the
canvas
like there's there's there's a thing
that says i want to be a great artist i
want to do a great job and that
self-talk
is
leveling up our necessity
lots of people have amazing strengths
but they don't get off the couch
because they don't feel it's necessary
to win
necessary to succeed necessary to serve
and high performers feel like it is
necessary that i show up today i do a
good job i help others sometimes some
answer in the spiritual realm they say i
feel called to do this i feel it is my
mission i feel god has given me these
gifts and i don't waste that and that
for them is a very spiritual emotional
connection to it's necessary for me to
kick some butt
do well deliver other people they really
gotta mentally
get themselves in that i'm a little in
between i have to
say things to myself
before i walk into a situation
to make me better
like before i came through those doors
like you have a bathroom out there and i
went in the bathroom and i do a little
self-talk to myself and i bounce in
place and i take 10 deep breaths and i'm
talking to myself so that i just i'm
ready reveal uncertainty
this one
is the opposite dynamic of how i used to
think of confidence right we think of
confident people as people are just like
you know it's like wonder woman right is
confident we think of superman is
confident who just knows everything
really what it turns out to be high
performers are a lot listen to this high
performers are a lot less superman and a
lot more clark kent
that's what it turned to be in all the
research with millions of data points in
all of my conversations high performers
were much more likely to reveal
things like
i don't know
things like
i'm i'm unsure
things like how do you think this should
go
things like could could you kind of help
me with this
like high performers literally
explicitly share
that they don't know how it's going they
don't know how it's supposed to go that
they need some help that they need some
mentorship that they need some guidance
that's confidence
confidence is not holding back
the deck of cards of your weaknesses
confidence
is a comfort with vulnerability
and when people say vulnerability they
often don't know what they mean when
we're talking about vulnerability
specifically related to confidence and
high performance like measurable
outcomes the thing that we can measure
and see is that high performers in group
meetings in team meetings in social
situations more often share their
insecurity
they more often say
i don't know how this is supposed to go
or you know they'll be the person you
know
at that fruit punch bowl who says you
know i don't really know anybody here um
i don't really know how to start to uh
meet some of these people could you
introduce me to somebody
and that's how they handle the social
networking where they're awkward
they instead of just sitting back at the
punch bowl drowning their sorrows and
feeling bad about themselves they engage
the person next to them say hey you know
what i feel kind of awkward here i don't
know a lot of people could you introduce
me
that's how high performers are handling
little situations in life they're not
the most confident person in the meeting
who goes i know everything here they're
the most confident going you know what i
don't know this here's my question what
do you guys think
and that is how you lead
confidently you reveal that you don't
know everything know your why is nice
know your why and give yourself edge for
it
what do you mean let me give you an
example two guys walking out on the
track field
who's gonna win well equal quality of
experience
similar times maybe they've raced before
the guy at the block so i'm going to bet
on is the guy who came out and said
i gotta do this for my mom
they have a reason to perform at
heightened levels
and they have connected to that over and
over
now again some of these duh brendan but
the finding the research is they just do
that more often
than underperformers or even you know
good performers yeah they're more
connected to their reasons why and
they're stirring it man it's like and
they do it from two angles one angle is
your your like your internal standards
like my values or my self-expectations
say i gotta crush this cause that's who
i freaking am yeah like when you walk
out you're like
you're not gonna you know screw around
on when you're playing handball you're
like this is who
i'm loose i'm an athlete yeah i'm gonna
kick some ass here yeah it's that self
expectation okay then though they pair
it
with external obligation
like my team needs me to do this
the deadline says this time there's some
kind of external
they don't call it pressure my family
something bigger than themselves
something bigger than themselves yeah
yeah and that's what that was another
thing i was surprised by they don't say
they they rarely use the word pressure
because they want it
like people who use pressure they don't
want it
but high performers
i found they want they like they're
connected i'm doing this for a bigger
cause a bigger reason a team or yeah
they're sometimes just like deadline
like i'm i'm an unbelievably high
performing writer when there's a
deadline
before that you know i'm not always on
my game so but if you have those reasons
so you gotta have your internal reasons
and your external reasons and then your
job is remind yourself of that more
often passion plus growth plus
contribution equals personal
satisfaction yeah
yeah it's like
those all coming together a lot of
people have never experienced
and it's hard for you and i'd say that's
personal development guys
but it's true there's a lot of people
who've never had those three completely
line up so they're not satisfied even
with
their job or their career or their life
because the passion isn't there
even if the passions are they don't feel
like they're growing but everybody who i
talk to do you remember that first
personal development book you read do
you remember that first time you wrote
tons of notes about what you wanted your
life to be about do you remember that
first time you watched the movie
inspired you to go change there was fire
there
because that learning it opened up your
mind to a new level of existence for you
and as soon as you saw it you were like
oh ambition hits your heart
and now if you can match it with
contribution and you can see
how
that passion or that fire or that
learning or that growth all aligns to
some type of impact now you're getting
me fired up because now i can see the
outcome
of all the work a lot of people don't do
the work because they don't believe the
outcome
that's interesting you know if
psychologists talk about the power of
expectancy um when we talk about
motivation there's only two things that
spark motivation one is ambition
and that is i want more
of or i want a greater depth of right i
want a greater depth of connection with
my lady that's ambition where i want a
better meditative practice that's
ambition all right i want to be better
at my job that's ambition so it starts
with ambition but ambition if it's not
coupled with what they call expectancy
in psychology you're screwed
expectancy says i believe that i can
figure that out i believe that i can
achieve that i believe that that is
possible for me
because if we don't believe it's
possible for me you can show them all
the results from a thousand people
right how many people say i want to get
in great shape
you know
tom i'm a new ketosis i'm doing the
hypnosis thing man and they they hop on
your instagram and but then they see
they see the cuts they see the changes
they see the transformations but they
don't believe it's possible for them
so they don't try
expectancy is their problem you gotta
bust through the beliefs to get them to
understand that it is possible for them
not for other people for them
and if you can open that gate for
somebody
and
often that's only achieved through
learning
then you get somebody who starts really
moving ahead forward
i mean really moving ahead like the
second they go wait that's possible for
me they'll try
50 stupid things right they'll try
anything
but if they don't lose possible they'll
just quit if you're in this place where
you're you really feel like you're
struggling
but you're like
i'm working so hard i would say what
she's telling me you know achievement is
not the problem alignment is once we got
her aligned i mean her life came back i
mean literally this person felt like
their life was a waste
like they had spent 20 years doing
something that wasn't the right thing
and there was a lot of guilt and shame
and frustration
there and i'm like europe
but she didn't feel
right because she wasn't in alignment
soon we got her in alignment i mean
literally weeks she changed i mean you
would have thought she had you know some
renaissance of the mind and it wasn't
that many things just sometimes you're
actually not off
by you know 50 feet like you think you
are you're you're off
by like four or five degrees
and if you can align your relationships
your career and your health back into
the right angle for you you come back at
life
if you want another amazing brand number
shard video check it out right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there brendan you want to be a writer
you can't write you have to actually
take an action that moves you forward
getting very clear on the mission i
think doubt is one of the greatest
enemies of our lives so if you're going
to go to a meeting sit down and say guys
i have 45 minutes today for this